jennifer aniston certainly knows all
about making big TV bucks but now she
has all new friends and her new movie
including Olivia Munn who gave Cameron
an exclusive tour behind the scene this
is the office Christmas party grant I
dove it so who's working this office
Christmas party with Olivia well
Jen's the mean boss the Grinch who wants
to steal Christmas away Jason Bateman's
the chief tech officer people get over
sir
hey John
in my workplace at SNL we're paid to be
imbeciles every second of this stopping
imbeciles we get so in trouble if you
are going to have intercourse tonight
please do not do it on company property
there's definitely a shorthand and a
confidence and it's sort of a trust that
we have with each other that's just this
is like not like it almost doesn't feel
like work what just how come a Z does
this batch get I got a special tour of
the set everybody's at lunch they have
no idea that we're inside the sets don't
need to fix Goofy's little gummies I was
not gonna help
Olivia also revealed she actually shares
a secret connection with co-star Jen's
husband Justin Theroux
you see back in 2010 when Olivia was a
correspondent on The Daily Show in New
York the two were drinking buddies and
friends you get me the best guy advice
he'd be like this guy stay with and that
guy that guy you're not gonna like did
he give you advice on there
he does like errands but Jen
and I met years ago she passed by me and
she goes hi Olivia
and I like in my mind just blew up I
could not believe that she actually knew
my name how fun I always loved hearing
about stars who get starstruck see
they're just like